we're just a few weeks out from final  fantasy 15 finally releasing but another  spin-off is on the way  I'm Tony and this is your mobile game  spot news update machine zone is the  developer behind iOS and Android hits  like game of war and mobile strike and  it's partnered with Square Enix for a  final fantasy 15 MMO on mobile devices  not much else has been said about the  game but Square says Machine zone has  quote trustworthy hands so there's a  good chance it'll be similar to the  studio's other titles we'll have to wait  for more information but don't be  surprised to see some Final Fantasy  characters in the palm of your hand  before too long  if mobile games aren't your style don't  worry Final Fantasy 15 is coming to ps4  and Xbox one on November 29th we've got  plenty of coverage up on GameSpot and  it's not stopping anytime soon to keep  up with all the biggest final fantasy  news you're already in the right place